the Consumer Electronics Show or CES as
it's known wrapped up on Friday after a
week of i popping unveilings including
the new LG TV with a 65 inch rollable
screen 8k TVs whatever those are you
turistic cars and a whole lot more CES
is a place where the future of tech is
discussed and displayed wired recently
published its best of CES 2019 and here
with some of the highlights as
editor-in-chief and CBS News contributor
Nicholas Thompson what happened in Vegas
a stay in Vegas
he brought toys give us the takeaway
what it should take away did not bring
the robot taxi those taxi I'm sorry to
say about a rollable TV screen yeah I
love that no the robot they're not they
don't totally work the rollable TV
screens but they will and they'll be
very functional you can put them new
places what about privacy privacy yeah
well that's one of the interesting
things about CES like CES is all about
optimism excitement invention meanwhile
the country when it thinks about tech
has been having these conversations
about privacy invasions and the tech
lash and what was interesting to me is I
really thought this would be the first
CES I went to everybody would be talking
about privacy and all these devices
would be introduced and they wouldn't
upload your contacts or they'd let you
cover up the camera and then the first
booth I go to it's a place where they
videotape your baby just see whether
they're asleep and they sell the data
right it was just no talk of privacy
it's so innocent there let's let's get
to these products will start with title
care which we have here on set yes
so title care was one of the new devices
that we named in our best of CES at
Wired it's a home medical device for
when your kid is sick right because when
your kid is sick you don't want to go to
the doctor because they're gonna just
lick all the other stuff touched by all
the other sick toys and it's probably
gonna get sicker so it's a little device
and what you do is you take this and you
plug like boy creates a call with a
doctor yep you plug to say the ear thing
in if your kid has oh wow or you drop
something so you couldn't really do like
a checkup
over this thing and the doctor can then
see in the ear the doctor had there's a
stethoscope
and so then you can have that
preliminary conversation with your
doctor and figure out whether you
actually need to go into the hospital or
wherever you need to go and most of the
time as everybody knows kids knows what
you do is you give them some water stay
home and take a nap and now also ICU
Baqi there yes this is two-factor
authentication which is something we at
Wired care a ton about which is what you
do is when you log in to something you
not only have your password you also
have a physical device that you plug in
you can plug your keychain with one of
these into your laptop right that's been
a big security improvement over the last
couple years what happened at CES is it
finally now works with iPhones you
bikini which does all this it's been
hard because if you can't have a UV key
that works with everything you have
then suddenly become less secure all the
way around so this was a big improvement
and something we were very excited about
adarand pop is the other one that we've
got here we don't have that we don't
have that one on set so that's a pop
socket right so we have two things we'd
like to put on our phones right we'd
like to put cases so they don't crack
and some of us like pop sockets right so
you can hold on to them on the back and
your selfies but the problem with the
pop socket is it sticks out it makes
your phone uncomfortable yeah that's why
I don't have one
so otter built a case with a pop socket
is built into think it's like such a
smart clever thing stuff and more cool
highlights in Wired magazine the Compson
thank you so much so many